our next award honors those who give a
film it's a visual concept and design
these artists whose work you're about to
see created the remarkable and unique
look of middle-earth of a man and tiger
lost at sea and of 19th century Russia
Paris and the American Civil War here
are the nominees for achievement in
production design Anna Karenina
production designed by Sarah Greenwood
and set decoration by Katie Spencer The
Hobbit an unexpected journey production
designed by Dan henna INSAT decoration
by Robinson and Simon bright way Mazar
off production design by Eve Stewart and
set decoration by Anna Lynch Robinson
Life of Pi production design by David
Grubman and set decoration by Anna panic
Lincoln production design by Rick Carter
and set decoration by Jim Erickson and
the Oscar goes to Lincoln
Rick Carter and generics
this is the first
for Jimmy Eriksson
or drinker partner very much not not
prepared for this
Jim Erickson who is a set decorator
shares this honor and all of us who
worked on this movie of Lincoln I think
in our own ways tried to be worthy of a
legacy that's way beyond all of us
especially Steven and Cathy and Tony and
Sally but of course Daniel who actually
convinced us that he was Lincoln and the
legacy that I think that he personified
for all of us goes to our heart and it's
worth far more than any gold that any of
us could ever have and I just thank you
and I love my wife Adele